die pflicht ein bodyguard ihr habt mich
zum eingang gebaut
hörst du mich noch meinen bildschirm ist
herausgerissen worden
ihr seht wahrscheinlich schon ich habe
nämlich vor einigen tagen er hat schon
mal nach vorne das sieht einfach so aus
dass wir die insel unter uns ja übel als
können wir gleich aufs dach springen von
diesen bei uns verdammt schwer damit
überhaupt dazu zocken so und wir machen
damit einfach mit mettwurst runde weil
wir die krassesten bluse und luca dachte
sich methode aber es kommen wieder zu
unserer erreicht
man sieht ist ja nicht an ich dachte
also wir haben halt ich hab halt diesen
und dann war das toll ich habe mir bei
diesem shader vorgestellt dann 80 mir ja
ok krass ich will nie wieder damit
spielen sollen etwa aber dann kamen so
im kommentar ja damit meine challenge
macht damit meinen runde petra und dann
dachte ich es mir wieso eigentlich nicht
und dann habe ich mir die zähne
reingepackt dann wollte max gerade hat
mich gefragt ob er aufnehmen kann mit
mir weil ich bin so ein mega besi und
haut bei und es im kasten ein
da ist ein typ bei uns max ich baue
gerade zum kopf zum 1
ich will jetzt raus er ist auch großer
wert jetzt heraus politik
ja ich laufe wohin manche haben sie auch
einfach nicht wenn jemand da ja schon
wieder jemand von roth bei uns ja fast
als alter ego ist denn unsere pace ein
bodyguard wirklich zum ein umgebaut
hörst du mich noch meinen bildschirm ist
herausgerissen worden
aber was war das denn mein bildschirm
ist kaputt nein
doch der zum blauen grundton wie soll
denn überleben einen zweiten bildschirm
ich habe auch ganz alten wirtschaft
weiter einer 10.000 jahre breit ist ich
bin runter sowie eine nicht einige
fluglinien so also wir haben noch der
klassiker drin wir haben immer noch die
gleiche karte bei max gruber und einfach
wieder fantasy gegangen ist der mitte
2010 ok ich hab zwar gold für bohmann ja
freunde es geht jetzt irgendwie nicht
also der zweite bildschirm geht gar
nicht ich hoffe es läuft alles wieder
noch mit der aufnahme auch wie mich das
abfahrt wie soll ich denn einem zweiten
bildschirm aufnehmen können
sein vor freunden auch nicht alles nur
wegen dieser scheiß challenge es kommt
aber niemand zu uns ich baue ich gerade
zu unserem stable formel dies so
schlecht wie max wo bist du so bist du
willst
wir sind team blau blau blau blau kannst
doch ein bogen ja deswegen holt wird mit
dem bogen holen jetzt irgendwann später
dann seid euch jetzt mal wie es aussieht
wenn man jemanden bogen schießt ich
schieße schlüssel nicht und außerdem
jedermann tier noch wohl und wenn nicht
sogar so hochtief würde der po geht
einfach direkt unter leute da nicht so
der fall geht aber direkt oder indirekt
da ich hier so hoch verliert direkt
richtig dumm einfach also damit zu
treffen ist mit das schwierigste auf der
kompletten nur noch schwieriger ist in
einem raum mit mark für überleben mit
einem gestoppt ich kriege ihnen doch
kein ding war ausnahmsweise minecraft
ist ein schlüssel wenigstens im rila ich
treffe ich halt nicht
ich habe sie getötet mit dem boden als
ob ich betont verdammt begriff was
machte gehen wir gegen wales zurück hast
du reisen sperrt wie crazy ist das denn
bitte ich verstehe diesen modus einfach
nicht dass es so krass ist so irre
mein kopf ist auch so was gerade
passiert
ich habe boxer getötet da könnte ich so
gut boxen oder liegt im eher wie eine
fluglinie in der luft liegend dieser
modus will mit ca auf einer skala von
eins bis 100 5 meter auf die eier ich
habe keine motivation zu ändern verloren
ach ich weiß nicht wie wir die
enterprise intelligence ein block nach
vorne oder hammer
euro aus dem budget ich habe mich am
plan einstellung zu hause
du hast bestimmt wurde nein als ob ich
ne na.de hole meine letzte rettung
ok ich kann probieren ist noch zu reißen
aber es wird verdammt schwer es wird
verdammt schwer so wie wenn sebastian
zulegen würde
wir werden sie besitzt du nicht ich bin
auf deren dach von wo auch jetzt macht
die shader übrigens mal raus damit ihr
seht jetzt wie es ihr ohne gott gut
freund das war's mit dem mit dem shader
wenn ihr andere shader kennt die
eventuell total crazy sind dann schickte
ihn mal lasst uns bitte nicht wissen
wollte was nie wieder machen
max irgendwo einer beschreibung ganz
unten